[Music]
foreign
I think therefore I am
the reading of all good books is like
conversation with the finest men of past
centuries
[Music]
if you would be a real Seeker after
truth it is necessary that at least once
in your life you doubt as far as
possible all things
[Music]
conquer yourself rather than the world
common sense is the most widely shared
commodity in the world
for every man is convinced that he is
well supplied with it
doubt is the origin of wisdom
except for our own thoughts there is
nothing absolutely in our power
it is not enough to have a good mind the
main thing is to use it well
foreign
to know what people really think pay
attention to what they do rather than
what they say
I desire to live in peace and to
continue the life I have begun Under The
Motto to live well you must live unseen
all things in nature occur
mathematically
there is nothing more ancient than the
truth
in order to improve the mind we ought
less to learn than to contemplate
divide each difficulty into as many
parts as is feasible and necessary to
resolve it
each problem that I solve became a rule
which served afterward to solve other
problems
because reason is the only thing that
makes us men and distinguishes us from
the beasts I would prefer to believe
that it exists in its entirety in each
of us
bad books and gender bad habits but bad
habits engender good books
it is best not to go on a great Quest
For Truth it will only make you
miserable
the destruction of the foundations
necessarily brings down the whole
edifice
whenever anyone has offended me I try to
raise my soul so high that the offense
cannot reach it
one should never judge anything unless
it is known
the first precept was never to accept a
thing as true until I knew it as such
without a single doubt
[Music]
my third Maxim was to try always to
master myself rather than Fortune and
change my desires rather than change how
things stand in the world
when it is not in our power to determine
what is true we are to follow what is
most probable
thank you
truths are more likely to have been
discovered by man than by Nation
to live without philosophizing is in
truth the same as keeping the eyes
closed without attempting to open them
[Music]
an optimist may see a light where there
is none
but why must a pessimist always run to
blow it out
we do not describe the world we see we
see the world we can describe
a state is better governed which has few
laws and those laws strictly observed
our convictions result from Custom and
example very much more than from any
knowledge that is certain
cause of human errors is to be found in
the prejudices picked up in childhood
the thinking of the mind is twofold
understanding and willing
illusory Joy is often worth more than
genuine sorrow
wonder is the first of all the Passions
the two operations of our understanding
our intuition and deduction
on these alone we must rely for the
acquisition of knowledge
any community that gets its laughs by
pretending to be idiots will eventually
be flooded by actual idiots who
mistakenly believe that they're in Good
Company
thank you your joy is your sorrow
unmasked and the self same will from
which your laughter Rises was oftentimes
filled with your tears
desire awakens only to things that are
thought possible
[Music]
there is a little gland in the brain in
which the soul exercises its functions
in a more particular way than in the
other parts
for each of us there is a set limit to
our intellectual Powers which we cannot
pass
[Music]
the mind effortlessly and automatically
takes in new ideas which remain in limbo
until verified or rejected by conscious
rational analysis
those who travel very slowly May yet
make far greater progress provided they
keep always to the straight road than
those who while they run forsake it
there is a great difference between Mind
and Body in so much as the body is by
nature always divisible and the mind is
entirely indivisible
and I shall always hold myself more
obliged to those by whose favor I enjoy
uninterrupted Leisure than to any who
might offer me the most honorable
positions in the world
traveling is almost like talking with
those of other centuries
so far I have been a spectator in this
theater which is the world but I am now
about to mount the stage
and I come forward masked
[Music]
among all those who up to this time made
discoveries in The Sciences it was the
mathematicians alone who had been able
to arrive at demonstrations
reason is nothing without imagination
[Music]
mathematics is a more powerful
instrument of knowledge than any other
that has been bequeathed To Us by human
agency
there is nothing so far removed from us
as to be beyond our reach or so hidden
that we cannot Discover it
[Music]
it is to the body alone that we should
attribute everything that can be
observed in us to oppose our reason
science is practical philosophy
[Music]
Sensations are nothing but confused
modes of thinking
if you want to develop your mind you
should think more not repeat
the dreams we imagine when we are asleep
should not in any way make us doubt the
truth or the thoughts we have when we
are awake
[Music]
hope is the desire of the soul to be
convinced that the dream will come true
nothing is more fairly distributed than
common sense no one thinks he needs more
of it than he already has
thank you for watching which quote did
you like best let us know in the
comments